you might have heard of a website called
only fans
over the last year or so
[Music]
only fans is one of the most exciting
tech companies in the world
[Music]
only fans allowed the content creators
to set the price
and gave them a generous 80 stay for
every dollar they made there's also a
generous tipping
system as well only fans just became
the single groundswell for
a lot of adult performers a lot of the
industry
in the same way that businesses like
zoom became a part of our
meeting culture in the same way as
payment businesses like stripe
only fans just became huge during the
[Music]
pandemic
people craved intimacy people craved
connections with people
and only fans delivered that only fans
delivered it well
only fans has just found a completely
new
audience of people who are willing to
pay money for access to
models adult performers but also chefs
and celebrities
they're keen not to be known as an adult
site for a porn site they don't like
those words
i'm just kidding that is not the kind of
content you're gonna see from me
with these celebrities jumping aboard
there is a genuine move away from
adult entertainment and pornography
towards being a social media site that
just allows famous people
to monetize on the content they already
create they already give away
on twitter and instagram that's a new
market
so only fans was founded in 2016 by
members of the stokley family an essex
based
family here in the uk tim stokley is
very much the face of only fans
he's the ceo he is the person who
gives statements he is thoroughly
believable
as the face behind only fans behind the
scenes you've got guy stokely now he's a
kind of old-school city of london a
retired banker he worked at barclays in
his time
he's the authority figure behind only
fans
the majority owner of only fans is
leonid ridvinsky
a 39 year old florida based tech
entrepreneur
ranvinsky is actually one of the richest
men in porn ever
neither larry flint nor hugh hefner were
ever forbes billionaires
we know he was born in ukraine he moved
to the u.s
and he studied economics at northwestern
university before only funds
rivinsky was most famous for my free
cams
a cam service there was live action for
adult performers
what we know about leonard rubinski is
scarce my colleague came to me
and said hey we've got this new
billionaire and you know we don't really
know anything about this guy
i do the obvious thing like you know
google them so i could start looking at
his more benign looking ones
then there are his other known websites
his porn websites
uh mike hunch was and turned out to be a
right hunch was that when
leo was a lot younger maybe he was a bit
more careless than he is today
i also have a couple of tools that i can
use to start looking at their internet
footprint this brings back
like a thousand results there are these
other sort of really strange websites
and they're essentially um they all have
their password or passes or something
like that
in in the name they're essentially
promising lists and lists and lists
of passwords for paid for websites
suspect he never actually really hacked
into websites or illegally
retrieve them partly because his own
company in a court document said
the way we make money essentially is
these porn sites for whom we offer
free access to they actually pay us
money every time they get click
[Music]
but there was something else which which
was much more concerning and a lot more
eye-catching
which was um some of these password
sites were offering logins to
what were described as underage
pornography
um even some referencing uh
models um under the age of you know 10
11 in some cases
um so pretty gruesome stuff he knew that
pedophiles were out there and he knew he
could make money from them by
getting them to click and when they did
click they didn't get that illegal
content there after they
just got taken through either to other
password sites on illegal content
that seemed to be the nature of his
business and this was happening sort of
from the late 1990s to the mid-2000s in
the mid-2000s
rivinsky caught onto the craze for
leaked celebrity sex tapes
even if they didn't exist he registered
sites for
ben affleck jennifer lopez and britney
spears
he did this because the websites would
still drive traffic
whether or not there was any tape on
there this is quite funny because
only fans this whole thing is you have
to pay to get this content
and we're going to pay these porn stars
and these celebrities
a fair amount he was essentially saying
you know back then
i'm going to give you free access to
these porn sites and so they're not
going to get your money
but you'll still get their content and
the fact that you have a majority owner
who
back in the day a has run you know these
big amateur porn sites
was once you know courting the attention
of leader files essentially even though
he wasn't giving them content
i think that really has to affect you
know what happens when the ipo is still
a lot of stuff we don't know about him
he's still a bit of a mysterious
figure
[Music]
you